you
when people warned me about someone the
label head or the publishing head that
somebody's difficult I'm in heaven I
just say bring them on and I can't wait
because when people are described as
difficult and have a reputation as
difficult it's ninety-nine percent of
the time because they've been
disappointed over and over again by
people who don't really know what to do
for them and i know i'm going to make
them happy and i can't wait to work with
them and that happens time after time so
when i hear someone's difficult I can't
wait to work with them
I think my most favorite subject was
Lena Horne because she embodies soul and
grace and elegance and street she
embodies everything and beauty great
beauty so she was a favorite subject
many of the jazz musicians whom are no
longer here you don't realize that its
history when it's happening and then
time passes and you look at a picture
and you say wow there's history attached
to that you know Dexter Gordon playing
you know in my studio for an hour after
the session things like that there's
been wonderful moments like that I look
at this sounds so corny but I love my
subjects I have to love them to do what
I do I have to fall in love with them to
create a successful portrait of them and
it's not confected it just has to be so
it's like a mother saying I love all my
children equally but I really do I i
love my subjects
robert rauschenberg one of my favorite
sessions actually I had never met him
and came to his studio where he lives
where he painted where he works he has a
building had a building and there was a
few minutes that I had to wait and there
was an incredible piece of his that was
forged of texture metal you know it was
probably a big rusted side of a truck or
something but it was this beautiful
textured metal and bob was great he was
just so wonderful and I didn't like what
he had on I you know I clothing as a big
component but that's another story so I
said can I look through his closet he
said sure so I picked a shirt and then
there it was there was this leather
jacket it was the same exact texture of
the metal so he lived for moments like
that and again that's what i mean by
paying attention that's what i mean by
mastering improvisation it's all there
you just have to find it so i grabbed
the shirt i grab the jacket and of
course in the picture that jacket and
that metal is one thing it's all organic
and wonderful and he was beautiful great
artists know who they are so there's no
excavating at all there they're happy to
share and I think that I'm really
blessed actually to be able to be in the
presence of them and to give them back
to themselves in my work it's really
wonderful I'm thinking aside from
rauschenberg same thing with roy
lichtenstein steen same thing these
painters they know exactly who they are
great jazz musicians they know exactly
who they are great opera singers know
exactly who they are Jesse Norman
there's not really work to do with Jesse
it's just centering in on exactly who
she is
Frank Sinatra Pablo Picasso Billie
Holiday Ray Charles Bob Dylan what does
Bob Dylan have that those other people
do not he's still here sebab call me